[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one of the benefits of
living for a while is you get to see how
the story ends it's sometimes a little
depressing if you're over 40 you
probably remember Robert rice he was
Bill Clinton's labor secretary he was a
liberal among moderates in that
administration but a thoughtful and
engaging person his views weren't
mainstream but he certainly wasn't
stupid or a hater well that was all
before Trump like a lot of people in our
ruling class robert rice is now a
completely different person just the
other day rice wrote that the entire
trump presidency ought to be annulled
not just ended prematurely that's no
longer radical enough but erased from
history forgotten by decree America must
reset to the first Monday in November
2016 like none of it ever happened we'd
have to retroactively Lee Photoshop an
awful lot of pictures but according to
rice it's the only remedy reality isn't
tolerable it should be banned rice was
dead serious apparently keep in mind
that 20 years ago people considered him
impressive some still do which tells you
a lot about the state of our
intellectual leaders people still defend
John Brennan too even after he revealed
on television that there's something
seriously wrong with him officials who
run the CIA ought to be sober and
reasonable and even-tempered it's too
powerful a job with too little oversight
and too little accountability for a
wacko
that would be dangerous for the country
and yet over the weekend there was
Brennan once again charging a political
opponent with a death-penalty offense on
the basis of zero evidence watch I've
been having a hell of a time here on
this show trying to get my guests to say
the word treason I think the president
is guilty of that and you used terms
like that you said after Helsinki it was
nothing short of treasonous which sounds
to me like treasonous treasonous is
defined as a betrayal of trust as well
as aiding abetting the enemy and so that
was the word that came to my mind
things are accelerating fast Trump is a
racist became Trump as a traitor which
has now become Trump is a non person who
must be erased from our collective
memory the left is officially out of
epithets all that's left is physical
harm who will be the first to call for
that
it feels inevitable at this point mark
Stein is an author and columnist and he
joins us tonight so what do you make of
annulling the trump presidency mark well
I think this is rather like the famous
episode of Dallas where after they wrote
off an entire season as not having gone
anywhere and and Pam Ewing stepped into
the shower and there was Bobby Ewing who
was supposed to be dead restored to life
and Robert rice seems to basically be
proposing the same solution here that
Robert rice will step into the shower
and there will be President Hillary
Clinton magnificently reside that's not
a bit too vivid for you actually as I
was halfway through that image vivid for
me but that does actually reflect this
the level of denial here if you were
called going back to November 2016 we
heard all this stuff about oh you know
America is unique in having the peaceful
transfer of power which I don't quite
accept I mean generally speaking when
they get a new prime minister in Denmark
they don't throw the old one off the
Parliament building or anything there
are other countries that have peaceful
transfers of power what room what's in
what's interesting here is is that
actually they can't accept that and and
the and the denialism which back a year
and a half ago was just like with fake
Newsweek covers showing the rightful
president is now extending to former
cabinet secretaries well that's actually
arguing for the erasure of the
historical record and sort of resetting
things to Year Zero and actually
is harmful to the so-called peaceful
transfer of power and in that sense rice
should be ashamed of himself so but
that's kind of the key here you have a
not just some pundit on ms CNN or
whatever but here you have a former
cabinet secretary in a well-regarded
what I mean I know him and he is a
legitimately smart guy and then a former
CIA director is not a legitimately smart
guy but still a former CIA director I
mean these are the pillars of the
establishment what is it macro question
about Trump that drives the ruling class
to say things like this irrational
things crazy things well I think there
is a general presumption that it's not
just that he won but that he shouldn't
have won and therefore because he
shouldn't have won he cannot really have
won and that's why you have to have this
the this basically this dance of
speculation now the trees and accusation
I think is actually facade treason is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy and
actually Russia isn't the enemy at the
moment in favor was President Obama who
mocked the very idea that Russia was
even a sort of geo political rival of
any kind so we're not at war with Russia
the idea that that is actually possible
of rising to the level of treason is is
faintly absurd but but I think I think
it's the need to deal Ajith um eyes and
and you know a couple of cycles ago that
just meant mocking the other guy as
being stupid and being unworthy of it
and all the rest of it but it's actually
gone on to something far more dangerous
which is actually D legitimizing the
entire system when you have when you
have just major political figures saying
that in effect the peaceful transfer of
power is not possible it can't possibly
happen therefore if it does happen it's
illegitimate it's not so much this will
that president that their dealer JIT
amaizing but actually the very
possibility of civilized self-government
exactly so if the supposed adults on the
left rice and Brennan and many others
are talking themselves into this frenzy
where each round becomes more extreme
than last how long before someone
convinces himself that you know we need
to storm the white we need to take
action like physical action here what
that's that's the terminus of this right
how could know well well that's what
makes this at the sound level ridiculous
I mean for a Bill Maher just before that
bit with Brennan said that this was the
third biggest crisis in the republic in
america's history the Revolutionary War
and then the Civil War and now this well
having another decaf macchiato and
finding another Canadian
singer-songwriter to date you're not
pledging your life your fortune and your
sacred honor are you by the way speaking
of treason if he is dating another
Canadian singer-songwriter that's like
George Washington dating a United Empire
Loyalists at the time of the
Revolutionary War so he's not he's not
even serious about what he's saying and
that's what makes it decadent if either
this is as Bill Barr says the third
great crisis in American history or it's
just something you guys are talking
about over you're Sauvignon Blanc for a
giggle but if they're not if they're not
serious about it
they shouldn't be saying it because
somebody will take it seriously and
that's the real danger meanwhile the
middle class dies and nobody gives marks
I thank you very much for that great to
see you thanks a lot Tucker